>>> Tonight, a special treat.
Former California governor and action star
Arnold schwarzenegger sat down with Dana bash
to talk about how he's combatted rising antisemitism
and hate crimes in America.
Dana, I'm envious.
What a privilege you've had.
I've been in his company before.
He is really interesting.
>> No question about it.
And especially on this topic.
He invited me here to los Angeles to usc.
He has schwarzenegger institute set up there
to focus on public policy.
And broadly, about bringing people together.
His focus lately has been about combatting
hate.
He called this forum a terminating hate.
I'm sure you get that.
And the whole idea was to bring people together
like a former skin head, which he did, and
a rabbi was there, to have a conversation
across lines, among people that don't normally
have
[9:36:37 PM]
people that don't normally have these conversations,
and his personal connection to this was fascinating.
>> You have worn so many hats in your lifetime.
A body builder, movie star, governor of California.
You're using this chapter of your life to
speak out against hate.
Against antisemitism in particular.
Why?
>> Well, it's not this particular -- it's
like anything that I see that really bothers
me, I get involved with it.
If it is the fight against fossil fuels, a
cleaner environment, motivating people to
get up and become successful, or if it is
prejudice and hatred that I've seen over the
years rise.
So it became kind of alarming to me.
You don't have to just sit there and watch
this whole thing.
I think that you can get involved and use
your platform to speak out about it because
of
[9:37:39 PM]
to speak out about it because of my history.
I come from a country that was part of the
second World War.
Austria, hitler himself was part Austrian.
And it is all because we let this grow.
This antisemitism and this hatred.
So I come from a place that has been done
once before.
And I don't want that to happen again.
>> You stood up at this forum and you said
--
>> And I was born with a father that was a
Nazi.
Think about that.
>> The air went out of the room.
I've heard you talk about your father but
not like that.
What made you say it that way?
>> You have to understand, when I improvise
a speech, I don't think about how I say something
[9:38:40 PM]
think about how I say something or what I
say.
>> You used the story of your father to try
to reach people who are getting sucked into
groups that propagate hate.
Talk about making that connection?
>> My father was, and so many other millions
of men were sucked into a hate system through
lies and deceits, and so we have seen where
that leads.
I've seen firsthand how broken those men were.
The kind of atrocities happened.
How many millions of people had to die and
then they ended up losers.
The confederacy loses.
They say, oh, this just doesn't work.
Let's just go and get along and love is more
powerful than hate.
[9:39:42 PM]
love is more powerful than hate.
>> In this video that did you last month --
>> I want to talk today about the rising hate
and anti-semitism we've seen all over the
world.
>> Reporter: Which was incredibly powerful
and has been seen how many times now?
>> Apparently, at least 100 million people
saw it.
And billions of impressions.
>> You drew this parallel between participating
in Nazi hate during World War II and hateful
ideology that is growing in the U.S.
Now.
Is that the path America is on right now?
>> I don't know if it is the path that we're
on but I notice the danger.
>> You put out another video after January
6th, 2021, and you compared the storming of
the capitol to crystal night when Nazis burned
synagogues, jewish businesses and homes.
About 30,000 jewish men were
[9:40:42 PM]
About 30,000 jewish men were taken.
That was the beginning of it.
What did you mean by that?
What did you see on January 6th that reminded
you of the beginning of years of hatred and
killing in Germany and Austria?
>> The first thing that came to my mind when
I saw the insurrection that this is very dangerous.
It is a wake-up call to let people know, you
have to take this seriously.
Not just like let's get those right wingers,
put them to jail.
No.
This is much more than that.
What creates something like that?
And sadly, I have to say, that no one really
has covered it well.
The insurrection.
Because they only said what they did was wrong
and they have to go to jail and punish them.
But no one really has gotten into why was
it that way?
[9:41:43 PM]
into why was it that way?
What powers do people have that are really
upset and angry with government?
>> Part of it is that they were told the election
in 2020 was stolen.
>> But remember that it is always kind of
the straw that breaks the camel's back.
So it's not that that would drive anyone to
Washington.
I think it was an unbelievable dissatisfaction.
There is so much anger.
>> You said history shouldn't repeat itself.
Donald Trump is now the front runner to be
the nominee of your party, the Republican
party.
Given everything you said, does that concern
you?
>> Absolutely not.
Being the front runner of one party and letting
them dig this hole deeper and deeper is going
to make it easy for the Democrats to win.
[9:42:45 PM]
Democrats to win.
It is sad to see that.
That they couldn't come up with a new talent,
a new face that is a reasonable, smart, intelligent
person that can lead this country in a Republican
way.
>> Do you think there's no way he would win
again?
>> No.
>> What if he did?
>> What a question.
I can guarantee you that he will go maybe
get the Republican nomination.
Then when it come down to the actual election.
There are too many people now that have seen
what he did as president.
I think when it comes to the majority on election
day, I think they will see the difference
between one or the other.
That believe me, I'm not the first one to
say, this is really great to have Biden back
as president.
No.
There's no better option, the way it looks
like now.
>> Connecting this back to January 6th.
[9:43:45 PM]
January 6th.
You say the country, you were leader, the
governor of a very big state.
How do you reach those people when they are
listening to the lies of the 2020 election
and a leader who is perpetuating that still?
>> They will be buying into it because they
want to.
Even when you hear the evidence.
For instance, fox, with tucker Carlson being
fired, by spreading the wrong news, and fox
going to court because they've lied intentionally.
Not mistakenly, intentionally.
Over and over again about this.
People hear that but it doesn't mean anything
because they just want to believe the election
was stolen.
Because trump is their man.
>> And that relates to the hate that you're
trying to stop and the, kind of the temperature
you're trying to help bring down in this country.
How do you do that?
>> It's not just that.
[9:44:47 PM]
Prejudice and hate goes in so many directions.
It is not if you believe the trump election
was stolen or not.
It has nothing to do with trump.
It has to do with just in general, all over
the world, we have this problem now that there
is this hate and prejudice.
We are talking about white against black,
black against white, immigrants, it's just,
you know, he's from over there and he's a
Muslim and he's a Jew